[Music]
on this saturday night
the emotional funeral for the excels
four fountains of sweetness were taken
away
three generations taken too soon the
large show of support for the family
killed because of their religion
the side meeting the unofficial talk
between trudeau and biden
and home on wheels why some cities in
canada
are trying to ban this lifestyle
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us hundreds of people gathered in london
ontario today to honor the assail family
three generations a mother father
daughter and a grandmother
were killed on sunday night while they
were out for a walk
police believe they were targeted
because of their muslim religion
tonight it is that faith that's helping
this grieving community come to terms
with a tragic loss
camille caramelli has more on the
touching tributes in tonight's
top story
the four caskets of the upsill family
draped in canadian flags a nod to their
new home
after immigrating from pakistan 14 years
ago
is an apt testimony of
the fact that the entire canadian nation
stands with them hundreds of supporters
from london ontario's muslim community
and beyond
came to the islamic center of
southwestern ontario
religious leaders led the crowd in
prayer mourning for the lives
lost salman abzul madiyya salman
yumna abzul and her grandmother talat
absol
four fountains of sweetness were taken
away
three generations taken too soon
the laws to our family immense but a
belief held strongly in the muslim faith
that all four are in a better place
never
think of those brothers
and sisters as dead
they are very much alive
they are with us earlier in the day a
private service took place at a nearby
funeral home
the upsell family had a few relatives in
london and the greater toronto
area but many came from pakistan the uk
and the u.s to be here
and support the lone survivor of the
attack
nine-year-old fayez ozil he remains in
hospital
now orphaned and unable to attend his
family's funeral
they've come in throughout the town
they're all going to be here to support
him now to make sure that he is taken
care of
family friends say he was surrounded by
loved ones in hospital
while watching the funeral it's a very
emotional day
i don't think they'll realize what has
happened until it's done
and that's natural with most funerals
especially for them because it's so
charged emotionally
as the procession left the islamic
center the four caskets
were taken to a nearby muslim cemetery
for another private service
a family and community now trying to
move on but hoping these senseless
deaths
spark a call for change
in response to this tragedy members of
all parties in the house of commons have
agreed
to organize an emergency national summit
to combat islamophobia
but no timeline has been set robin
camille caramalli in london ontario
to breaking news out of saskatchewan an
rcmp officer has died
while on duty the bounties say
26-year-old constable shelby patton
was killed this morning while following
two suspects driving a stolen truck
east of regina during the course of the
stop
while outside of his police vehicle
kosovo patton was struck and killed by
the truck
sadly constable patton died at the scene
the vehicle fled the scene and less than
two hours later two suspects were
arrested in a rural area
a man and woman are now in police
custody the rcmp's major crimes unit has
taken over the investigation
and we have more breaking news with
global's continuing investigation into
misconduct within the canadian armed
forces mercedes stephenson joins us now
from ottawa
mercedes what's the latest
well robin there's been a lot of concern
about how serious the commitment is in
the canadian armed forces in terms of
rooting out and dealing with sexual
misconduct
it's been something that we have seen
leaders at the highest levels call for
and of course the most prominent case
was that broken by global news
with the allegations of sexual
misconduct against general jonathan
vance he's now retired but he was the
chief of the defense staff
global news has learned that general
vance was
out golfing with two of the most senior
members of the canadian armed forces
this week he was at a golf course in
eastern
ottawa having a round of golf with these
two very senior officers and they are
vice chief of the defense staff
general mike rulo he is the person who
the military police report to
the same military police who are
investigating general vance right now
on those allegations of sexual
misconduct which retired general vance
denies
also present was the head of the
canadian navy admiral craig baines
admiral baines runs all of canada's
warships and of course one of the most
high-profile
alleged victims is a woman in the
canadian navy who has made allegations
against admiral art mcdonald so you have
the person who the military police
report into as well
as the second in command of the canadian
armed forces along with the head of the
canadian navy
out golfing with somebody who is under
military police investigation right now
for sexual misconduct
the sources we spoke to were deeply
concerned about this
deeply concerned about the message that
it sends while publicly encouraging
women to come forward but privately
socializing with somebody who's under
investigation
i have spoken with both the minister's
office and i've also spoken with
the department of national defense the
minister's office said
that they considered these allegations
uh not allegations they're saying they
are aware that the golf game happened
now they didn't know about it until
media started contacting them
but they say that this is troubling and
unacceptable and that the minister is
going to be talking to the chief of the
defense staff
against next steps for these two very
senior officers
the military itself is saying that they
recognize the seriousness of this matter
they're also trying to get some facts
before they proceed with next steps
but robin you can imagine in an
environment where women have said that
they are
afraid to come forward afraid their
allegations will be taken seriously that
they have concerns that there is an old
boys club that is operating
and beyond that uh they're concerned
about the independence of the military
police
this is something that is raising a lot
of eyebrows in ottawa tonight
robin mercedes stevenson reporting from
ottawa thanks for that
dealing with china's communist
government that topic dominated talks at
the g7 summit today
it's crucial for canada because of the
two canadian men
languishing in chinese prisons our prime
minister has yet to officially meet with
the u.s president to discuss the matter
but justin trudeau managed to snag a few
moments with joe biden
here's abigail beeman with the side
meeting at the summit
the famous red arrows treated world
leaders to a dazzling fly
past but at the g7 the new american
president is the real
star it's a biden show and it's an
opportunity
for for joe biden and the closest allies
of the united states to demonstrate that
they're going to be working together on
a range of issues
justin trudeau has not yet secured a
formal bilateral meeting with the leader
of our closest neighbor
in summit speak trudeau scored some pull
asides instead
in a brief conversation saturday morning
the pair discussed the canada u.s
border neither side ready for a
reopening announcement
trudeau also raised the issue of the two
canadians detained in china
and he talked about michael kovrick and
michael spavor with the whole
g7 team when the uk prime minister asked
trudeau to lead a discussion about
china overshadowed again though by a
bold american proposal to counter
china's belt and road initiative
the superpower pours billions of dollars
into other countries infrastructure
stoking concerns about increased
influence and debt
the new biden build back better world
plan aims at helping
poor countries with infrastructure but
there's no costing
and no word about what canada thinks of
the plan
trudeau sat down with three other
leaders today
from the newest to the most senior your
perspective and your voice
resounds strongly through the g7 table
when the german chancellor retires this
fall
justin trudeau becomes the most senior
leader at the summit
but what kind of leadership emerges this
weekend on china
climate change and the specifics of the
vaccine sharing agreement
still remain to be seen with more
details expected sunday
when the summit wraps up abigail beeman
global news
falmouth england and when the g7 summit
ends the american president will meet
with vladimir putin
the first face-to-face meeting between
the two leaders since joe biden won the
election
relations between the two countries are
at an historic low and as jennifer
johnson reports
biden aims to press russia's president
on cyber attacks
linked to the kremlin u.s president joe
biden has said he wants a stable and
predictable relationship with russian
president vladimir putin
but at the g7 summit he's kept a tight
lip on what will be discussed when the
two leaders meet in switzerland
mr president what's your message to
putin i'll tell you after i deliver it
putin says he's going into next week's
summit with u.s russia relations at a
historic low
the russian leader had a close
relationship with former president
donald trump who he called colorful
but believes he can work with biden
president biden of course
is radically different from trump
because president biden is a career man
he has spent virtually his entire
adulthood in politics the white house
says biden will confront putin on
several
thorny issues that includes human rights
that includes
incursion on the ukrainian border that
includes cyber attacks
the biden administration is getting heat
from congress to slap new sanctions
against the kremlin
after cyber attacks allegedly from
russian criminals
hit america's economy the latest
shutdown one of the world's largest meat
suppliers
another against colonial pipeline caused
major gas shortages along the east coast
only until we have consequences to bad
behavior will the bad behavior stop
putin calls allegations that russians
are behind the attacks
nonsense he also denies his country is
going to supply iran with satellite
technology
to target u.s military
it's just fake news at the very least i
don't know anything about this kind of
thing
[Music]
putin also scoffs at allegations he's
had any hand in the deaths of several of
his critics
president biden has called putin a
killer the new man in the white house is
going into this summit not shying away
from tough talk
and an even tougher agenda jennifer
johnson global news
washington coming up a canadian
university is looking for a leader
experienced
in psychedelics
the university of calgary is searching
for the country's first
psychedelics research chair there's
growing interest in the use of
mind-altering compounds like ketamine
mdma
and psilocybin to treat mental health
issues psychedelic therapies can be
difficult to access
because of limited medical evidence
supporting them but as heather york's
west explains
a calgary philanthropist is hoping to
change that
for nearly a decade john finley fought
with suicidal thoughts
almost every day i had an incident
in the hospital and
when i got out my doctor he said well he
says there's really only one hope left
for you
and that's this ketamine treatment used
for years as an anesthetic
ketamine is one of the only psychedelic
therapies readily available to canadians
as a treatment for mental illness
still it can be difficult to access for
each appointment finley must make a
five-hour drive
from his home and medicine hat to the
nearest clinic in saskatoon
i had worked in acute care for about
seven years
lots of patients with treatment
resistant depression that were coming
into hospital
over and over and just not able to get
any relief
dr hooper's clinic provides ketamine
therapy and ketamine
supported psychotherapy to patients from
across western canada
but she'd love to one day offer other
psychedelic therapies
too i think there are a couple things
that are holding us back
right now the stigmatization and
criminalization
i think the way to remove those barriers
is to start with
with the research calgary trader jim
parker felt compelled to help after
seeing a family member benefit from
ketamine
his 3 million donation will help
establish
the country's first research chair at
the university of calgary
i think it's going to fast track this
field of science
you know quite significantly
in terms of actually taking it from just
an idea into something that we can
implement
or not taylor cautions that while some
early research has been promising
there is also evidence these therapies
may not be effective for all
i judge how it's working by three things
really
am i depressed do i have a suicidal
thought
and my anger and all three of those
i no longer have there is no doubt in
john finley's mind
ketamine therapy saved his life more
research he hopes will make these
therapies
more accessible to all heather urex west
global news
calgary still ahead the issues facing
india's
three-tiered health care system
you're watching global national
india has been hit hard by the pandemic
it has recorded more than
29 million cases of covet-19 second only
to the u.s
many factors contributed to the spread
of the virus including
high population density a more
transmissible variant
and the country's three-tiered health
care system
arabella sibaluck reports
rajkumar singh's brother-in-law has been
admitted to a covet ward in delhi
but it wasn't easy he blames the
government
and people in positions of influence who
get access to critical hospital
admissions
faster than people from his
socioeconomic background or neighborhood
it is very difficult to get an admission
in hospital we couldn't find a free bed
for the last four days we went through
all the hospitals but there was no
admission anywhere
but i managed to get it at this
government hospital here
he isn't the only one but few people we
asked wanted to comment publicly
many are also reluctant to confirm if
they've had to offer bribes for a
hospital admission
bribing or bakshish as it's referred to
locally
is a common administrative practice here
but the reality is the big people here
don't have the hassles we do
they get a good and prompt service
common people like us don't get that
too often the quality of care afforded
the sick and dying comes down to class
she was able to get hospital admission
but died when the oxygen she needed to
live
was turned off since he couldn't visit
he got the help of a hospital assistant
so he could see her
via video call the night before she died
how are you kidding me
i can say this hospital doesn't care
anymore they aren't caring towards covet
patients
patients are all the same hospitals have
been operating beyond capacity
for weeks there are a total of 700 000
beds in public health institutions
across
india estimates suggest another 1.2
million beds are available in private
hospitals
combined that's less than 2 million beds
for a population
of 1.3 billion as the country battles
the world's
largest covert 19 crisis statistics show
there are just
95 000 icu beds and 48 000
ventilators available canada and other
countries
have sent aid money antiviral drugs and
badly needed ventilators
but more help is needed
we went to about four to five hospitals
there they didn't have
any oxygen cylinders there was a lot of
struggle to get one
rural areas are often poorly equipped
but even around the state of delhi
people risk traveling to the capital
city where there are more medical
facilities
to plead for access to a coveted wing
the public health system in india
already has
three tiers which tend to reflect the
rural to urban divide
but even in cities like here in delhi
there are pockets of migrant workers and
daily wages
who would not have the right connections
let alone the facilities to get admitted
to a coveted ward
within a public or private hospital
where this
leaves people like here is a question
that remains to be answered arabella
cibola global news
delhi up next home
on the go what's steering so many people
to live
in their vehicles
queen elizabeth served up some laughs
when she insisted on using a sword
to cut up a cake the dessert was for g7
leaders on the first night of their
three-day summit in cornwall england
the queen was offered a knife but said
the ceremonial sword was
more unusual eventually the duchess of
cambridge stepped in to help
this is the first time britain's royals
are taking part in g7 events
if you search the term van life on
social media you'll find millions of
posts
most photos show a bohemian lifestyle or
sense of adventure
but the nomadic lifestyle of living in a
vehicle isn't always romantic and
carefree
for some it's all they can afford kayla
mclean explains
[Applause]
at this shop vans are converted into
homes
since the pandemic started madison
mcnair and her husband's business
has been nonstop it's been really
incredible
so we're already booking into 2022 and
2023.
van life the lure of freedom and travel
in a self-contained home on wheels
has given rise to a social media
phenomenon which in part
has been fueled by covet 19. for some
it's choice for others it's necessity
rent's expensive jobs are in stable how
do i sign a 12-month lease
if my job won't give me a 12-month
stability these vehicles are
far more about freedom self-control
autonomy this is also another place that
we stay at sometimes
in squamish b.c thomasina pigeon lives
in this van with her 14-year-old
daughter
feels like the way that i'm supposed to
live when i'm in a house i feel really
restricted
while tomasina prefers this lifestyle
she couldn't afford to pay rent
even if she wanted to i don't really
make that much money i own my own
business but
the amount of money that i make is below
poverty level with job losses
skyrocketing rent and the booming
housing market
some people have been forced into
vehicle living and as canada's
affordable housing crisis worsens
tensions between cities and van dwellers
seems to be growing
some municipalities are cracking down on
rvs
trailers and vans illegally parked on
streets squamish is no exception
passing by-law changes that would
prevent people sleeping in their vehicle
overnight
in certain public spaces thomas cena
co-directs an advocacy group
fighting the bylaw i think the bylaws
and the laws in general need to
reflect this growing reality that a lot
of people are choosing vehicles
as homes and it's a trend and it's not
going to go away
karen elliott is the mayor of squamish
she says the amendments are to manage
the tourist population and not aimed at
long-term vehicle residents
it is not targeting a people that call
squamish home
full-time it really is about managing
the influx of thousands
of vehicles each summer and thousands of
people that are looking for a place to
stay
back at the shop there's no slowing down
and the couple knows the van life trend
will continue
out of desire or need ultimately
it's about taking leaps and finding what
works for you and apparently in pandemic
times if you've decided you don't like
your van there is someone that will buy
that van
kayla mclean global news toronto
to learn more about why some
municipalities are now cracking down
on van lifers watch the new reality
tonight at 7 pm
on global and that is global national
for this saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is spiller's cove in
trinity bay newfoundland and labrador
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching
and i'll see you back here tomorrow have
a great night
[Music]
you